hey so I was just getting some work done
the other day and I was wearing the Moto
360 that day and I got a quick email
notification didn't respond to it didn't
even have to take out my phone and I
thought yeah that's neat but then I
realized I haven't reviewed this yet so
let's do that real quick this is the new
Moto 360 I don't know what it is about
this 360 but I keep coming back to it as
my sort of de facto SmartWatch obviously
the competition has gotten way better
since the first one but still give it
credit for sort of starting the circular
revolution we see today and a focus on
design anyway this 2015 Moto 360 is a
really minor upgrade from the original
and pretty much every way so it'll look
familiar here is everything that's new
number one the design okay not really
it's pretty much the same design but you
do get a couple improvements here and
there the lugs that connect the watch to
the bands are for one much easier to
remove quickly so interchangeable bands
are much easier now I have the leather
one that it came with you can see just
by removing both of them it will be easy
to change to whatever other ones you buy
and I now have some texture in the bezel
of mine here you can see which is
because I chose that in Moto maker this
is actually the best new feature the
Smart Watch compared to the competition
the ability to build your own with any
combination of the band and body colors
and bezels built to order right out the
box so you can build a pretty dope combo
to your liking I went with a pretty
clean all-black look as you can see
pretty toned down but that's my choice
and actually think having a black bezel
sort of blends in with the display more
and with the black watch face that also
kind of hides the bar at the bottom
which still holds the ambient light
sensor and display drivers you pretty
much get used to it being there alright
number two new thing is the specs one of
the biggest concerns with the first moto
360 if you remember was the slower
outdated OMAP chip they gave it so this
new one is now rocking literally a
quad-core Snapdragon 400 new GPU and
half a gig of ram so that concern is
pretty much wiped and performance is
consistently pretty smooth on the Moto
360 interestingly it's not the smoothest
performance I've seen in any SmartWatch
though I'd still give that edge to stuff
like the Apple watch and even Samsung's
gear s2 just as far as pure smoothness
of graphics goes but among android wear
smartwatches
this is pretty much as good as it gets
now here's an interesting thing the
ambient mode
that leaves the display on and dim
forever is turned on by default when you
get the new 360 which you would think
with a small battery on a SmartWatch and
an LCD display not an OLED like the
Huawei watch you'd think that would kill
the battery life but it has easily made
it through a full day for me usually
with more than 30% left with ambient
mode on so if you turn ambient mode off
and let the display fully sleep in
between waking it this thing can go full
two days between charges which is a nice
improvement and the best part is since
it's a small battery if you ever find
yourself low on a charge the wireless
charging is really fast so you can juice
up in under an hour from being dead so
you know I just left ambient mode on the
only weird thing I noticed is some watch
faces overlaps with notification text
while its ambient but that never
mattered because when I light it up and
look at it everything snaps into place
and into color this is definitely a
better experience than the first mode of
360 it even actually works with the
iPhone now despite you know much more
limited control over how notifications
work on iOS technically though that also
makes it a competitor to the Apple watch
for some buyers bottom line though I'm
less of a SmartWatch guy than I was
about a year ago I don't wear one every
day anymore but it's nice to see
improvements in these neat little pocket
computers that you can put on your wrist
especially in design we might be asking
if it's worth upgrading over the old one
I would say yes even if only for that
improved battery and performance but the
competition has gotten a lot better - so
look out for a roundup video of the best
wearables that you can get this year
either way thank you for watching this
one and I'll talk to you guys in the
next video peace
you